pas
[Musique]
la ministre d outre-mer à nous durant
actuellement sur mon s'est rendu à la
mosquée de saint denis cet après midi
pour visiter ce lieu de culte puis si tu
as tout cas s'est rendu à la chambre de
commerce et industrie pour un haut
conseil à la commande publique
parmi les nombreux sujets abordés celui
des radiers compétents du département
avec le département nous avons annoncé
un plan de suppression des radiers ici à
la réunion nous avons effectivement que
ce sont des risques forts pour les
habitants du déo
c'est ça va dans le sens de ce que je
voulais c'est à dire le zéro
vulnérabilité et bien c'est 9 millions
pour cette année c'est un programme
d'offre globale qui dépasse les 150
millions et bien puisqu'il ya un an
n'est pas au rendez vous financier dans
les opérations logement parce qu'elle
n'existe pas où elles n'ont pas été mis
en route et bien on va re dispatcher là
encore intelligemment
quand il est encore temps les crédits
pour au bénéfice de la réunion et je
remercie le président du département
d'avoir joué le jeu de se dire et bien
dans un tiroir j'ai un projet on en a
besoin c'est la sécurité des gens
puisqu'on fait pas assez de logements il
fauda fongibilité intelligente et bien
je les fais avec le département vous
savez madame la ministre des autres mais
nous annoncer que l'état allait
accompagner le département dans son plan
de d'élimination des radiés il y a près
de 160 radiers sur les routes
départementales et nous avons un
programme qui veut que chaque année 20
septembre de radiers sont améliorées eh
bien nous allons pouvoir les beaucoup
plus vite
d'ores et déjà donc l'état nous annoncer
la mise en place d'un fonds de 8
millions d'euros au profit du
département de la réunion pour justement
accompagner cet effort sera
d'amélioration des radiés et je peux
vous le dire que nous allons utiliser
ces financements pour remédier à
plusieurs radiers dans les hauts de
l'île je pense par exemple à bellemène
saint paul je pense aussi dans les eaux
du sud par exemple le ouaki ou d'ores et
déjà nous allons pouvoir mobiliser des
fonds pour mener les études et bien sûr
réaliser les travaux dans les délais
convenables pour qu'enfin et bien
trouver une solution radier du ouaki on
trouve une solution plusieurs radiers
qui pénalise la vie dans les eaux de
l'île
donc c'est ce qui nous a été annoncé cet
après midi
et bien sûr nous avons travaillé en lien
avec le service de l'état doit mettre en
place ce plan radier plus rapidement que
ce qui avait été prévu au départ
[Musique]